I will particular the Lodi Arnold on the
way another what you want to tell you a
little get-together in Chennai India
there's a tiny camera repair shop run by
a man named Joseph say car I lie at the
Sagan brother party but worldwide on the
Birdman Andrade say car got his nickname
because every day he feeds thousands of
hungry parakeets on the roof of his home
here under the other module da da da de
la marea Dover weird namacarya farmer
Quran Allah Allah nom nom nom about how
much we did the 2006 tsunami that hit
Southeast Asia flooded parts of India
and displaced thousands of birds sake
are noticed a pair of parakeets outside
of his home and set some rice out for
them then more started to show up and
well even the flag doing the personal
and reflect upon that era where even the
worried 8000 parodies of it feeding 8000
pair keeps twice a day is a great
expense say car spends about 40 percent
of the money he makes from repairing
cameras buying food for the birds
inaudible archivo de orizaba
but for the Birdman of Chennai there's
more to life than money
fernanda wall calum apana went to Tevin
up anime Val kala Panna one take over
money they make a Tara I'm not their
wikimedia celebrate upon a sommelier
bill are supported under one of them you
know what we're not gonna give me the
money he's gonna be seen under motives
on my car normally anode economía de
curtidores moving jolla we didn't
exactly a weird electronic in it no no
no Diana be moti
you
[Music]